bonjour à toutes et à tous bienvenue
pour cette petite vidéo des vacances
vidéo tranquille avec sophie donc
aujourd'hui on va regarder le trailer de
gameplay tâche est donc la série netflix
animé qui se passe dans l'univers de
jurassic world donc parce que se faire
une petite vidéo réaction sophie tu ne
l'as pas vu encore non non non moi non
plus ok no 2 de la vue moi j'ai vu des
petites images quand même donc je sais
un peu quand même hein comme attendu
[Rires]
donc on ça va être cool surprise donc
c'est un petit trailer il dure une
minute donc normalement la vidéo ne
devrait pas être trop longue
sauf s'il ya vraiment des normes d
énormes italie bien d'accord que
jurassic web pour l'instant c'est une
saga qui a été quand même plutôt
décevante
oui c'est une saga qui y voit le premier
le premier à passable pour moi et avec
des jolis visuels y avait des jolis
visuels
il est clairement rattrapé par la scène
finale de combat non voilà l'enfant qui
était en moi s'est réveillé durant cette
scène dont qu'il a il a clairement il a
clairement réussi son coup de d'être le
jurassic park que je voulais voir quand
j'avais jamais quel âge on avait six ans
quand il est sorti quand j'avais six ans
c'était le jurassic park que j'aurais
voulu voir quand j'avais 6 ans le
jurassic park on a eu quand j'avais 6
ans il était un peu plus sombre et un
peu trop adulte un peu effrayant
le 2 bompas été une catastrophe
le prometheus 2 de la saga
alors oui il est joli par un moment mais
alors de dire ça ça se fait au prix de
ça se fait au prix de tout le reste quoi
c'est dommage enfin un joli film au prix
de tout le reste et en particulier de la
cohérence interne de la saga c'est à
dire que le 2 n'est même pas cohérent
avec jurassic voir le premier est alors
là et encore moins avec la saga jurassic
park
donc bref mais tout ça j'ai déjà listé
donc là on part quand même plutôt avec
un a priori négatif en mai gans le passé
des mains si on ferait pas cette vidéo
si non mais on demande qu'à être
agréablement surpris à côté de ça mais
ça va être une grosse crise de fou rire
non on va certainement passer il faut
avoir de la bienveillance quand même
c'est une série animée
il y aura des oui on n'attend pas la
même qualité ne plus voilà on n'attend
pas la même chose d'une serre mais voilà
donc on est sur la page officielle de
jurassic de jurassic world le trailer
est là vous êtes prêts à aller
elle est prête suis-je prêt jamais assez
[Rires]
on peut déjà rien que l'image et à la
position des bras ils ont toujours pas
corrigé ils ont toujours les bras c'est
une série animée
on l'a dit ça va être moins critique il
porte avec un petit 1 cette vidéo est
sponsorisé par par all starz qui porte
encore ses chaussures non les quatre
séries animées visiblement parce que
même moi même mois un jour j'en ai porté
ce qui veut dire que c'est très ringard
bref c'est parti à musique la musique
[Applaudissements]
c'est très dangereux
c'est encore échapper
ou bien ça se passe en parallèle c'est
cet du premier film
[Musique]
j'aime bien les mules et ceux qui
servent à rien du double sont encore là
[Musique]
le petit frisson de la fin évidemment
évidemment ou là bas c'était pas mal
c'était court je m'attendais vraiment à
plus court mais intense
ouais on se remet juste pour faire des
arrêts sur image à ce qu'aulas va
changer le design des vies c'est du coup
maintenant ils vont dans un parc avec
les ors et les véhicules ils sont pas
fermées on est d'accord que dans tous
les safaris les véhicules ils sont
fermés de base
même si on va voir des herbivores je
suis quand même un problème sonne sonne
quand même quand on va voir des girafes
le véhicule est fermé c'est là tu vas
voir des trucs je ne sais pas combien de
fois data and girafe ça fait enfin on
est d'accord que bon mais ça c'est assez
vrai depuis le début de la saga jurassic
world c'est à dire que quand on les
voyait faire du canoë à côté des
dinosaures quand on les sait pas ces
genres de sécurité enfin il courait vers
le désastre déjà ça
non même actuellement dans les eaux dans
les réserves dans tout ce que tu veux tu
vas en véhicule fermé demande même que
les fenêtres soient fermés d'ailleurs
tous les accidents c'est quand les
fenêtres ouvertes
clairement oui voilà non allez y les
véhicules ouvert ce n'est pas une bonne
mais du coup ça se passe enfin on voit
les mêmes dinosaures que dans la saga
originale donc ça a l'air de se passer
dans un truc différent parce que ça
s'appelle quand on est assez nombreux et
du coup ils vont y campe au milieu entre
ryad et vidéos
eyad des prédateurs lanta bas ceci dit
tu peux faire des fois tu peux faire du
camping 2 en safari je le dis on a tu
peux faire du camping sa part m et un
intérêt à avoir des guides et était
plein ou à temps que tu as à ranger
c'est ça le fait qu'à me vois pas le
ranger avec le fusil ne veut pas dire
que voilà non c'est sûr j'ai apprécié
enfin je veux bien imaginer la taille du
fusil pour abattre quand une fois tu
vois les infrastructures teddy vous avez
construit tout ça sur un volcan
bigote pour la salsa jamais de la vie
[Rires]
la position de la tête du bras kyo enfin
et du gier à faty temps parce que ces
gouvernements inspiré du géra faty temps
beaucoup plus que du brachiosaure way la
loppsi enfin maintenant la tête elle
était à un angle enfin le coup ils
étaient 1 500 glisse comme ça non ça
c'est plus diplodocus mais les
brachiosaures idées ils ont les bras ils
ont des bras qui sont plus longs que les
jambes donc le coup il va être un peu
plus comme ça qu il ait jamais comme ça
voilà beaucoup donc ça reste les
dinosaures des kivu ça ça reste une
écologie de brouteurs des tranches de la
canopée les plus hautes
contrairement au diplodocus qui était
vraiment une tour 2 à gazon enfin les
diplô décidé d'ailleurs qu'ils étaient
des tondeuses à gazon
mais là le sas et s'est directement
inspiré du girafe à titan de berlin dont
on sait qu'il est qu'il est exagérément
redresser ouais mais disons qu'ils n'ont
toujours pas connu
en même temps même berlin n'a pas
corrigé ils ont fait les rénovations
début des années 2000 choix et ils l'ont
mis encore plus l'eau ça a rendu fou
tout le monde et donc ça c'est de
minutes
c'est l'un des must pour tous ceux qui
en demande et parce qu'on en a pas eu
assez des dinosaures mutants et du coup
alors un demi nus s'il est toujours sur
le parc donc la wii si l'un d'eux minus
est toujours là ça veut dire que ça se
passe avant ou pendant le premier film
du coup parce que ça pourrait alors ils
ont encore ressusciter la domus
puisqu'ils ont les gènes de toute façon
ici dit ça veut dire qu'ils ont encore
reconstruit jurassique world / o le même
si sur une île différente du made in
dans ce cas là ce serait à mon avis ça
se passe avant le premier fin ou pendant
le premier puisque après on voit
s'échapper
c'était pas les fameux pull rose or on
va remettre un petit peu je sais pas
j'ai pas eu le temps de voir la crise
que c'était il ya clairement un clin
d'oeil au premier jurassic park là avec
le dinosaure qui défonce la l'arbre
voilà cette scène là là il ya un clin
d'oeil au premier jurassic park
mais je sais pas qu'elle dit non parce
que c'était ça va peut licencier un peu
à ça à l'air de tincques c1 à belize au
rider ça doit être un car nos torts les
petites cornes sur la tête là les petits
bras très mauvais temps c'est
définitivement un quart nord est
c'est elle qu'il faut vraiment que la
truck elle soit moisi un toit qui va
faire ça faut vraiment que la bûche
elles soient complètement moisi pour que
carnot tort c'est pas non plus si gros
xsara puis les crânes le crâne est
vachement fin et dédicacé
non ça c'était l'un d'eux me muscler
fameux pouce opposable de l'inde minutes
parce qu'évidemment intelligence égale
puisse se poser à l'eau potable
et bien entendu on ne peut pas être
intelligent son pouce opposable quand
bien même on le voit jamais se servir de
ses pouces ou du sable d'ailleurs alors
qu'on le voit être très intelligent
c'est un nouveau s'investissent à sierra
cosworth
ça ressemble ça doit être inspira cause
or avec une seule corne les fronts je
connais pas la liste officielle
il ya une liste officielle des
dinosaures de jurassic world je la
connais par coeur je la connais pas du
tout en fait moi je suis jamais allé sur
le site c'est la première fois que je
mets sur le sifflet donc ça doit être à
ce tir à cause org
voilà paré ça promet quand même beaucoup
de nouveaux dinosaures encore c'est
marrant parce que les dinos en fait les
personnages sont pas réalistes les
humains le dire sont pas spécialement
réaliste alors que les dinosaures sont
presque aussi réalistes que dans le film
façon même niveau de réalisme près de
fait toujours discuter de la qualité du
réalisme des dinosaures mais les
personnages sont clairement des
personnages de dessins animés alors que
les dinosaures sont plutôt des trucs
tirée du film c'est intéressant nîmes au
niveau graphique on n'a pas l'impression
qu'ils sont sur le même plan de
l'existence six mois ça fait très manga
voilà où la scéne l'arrêt survie
[Rires]
pourquoi je fais ça c'est l'attitude
imagine à la fin de la scène allait
prendre son café ça soit pour coach
chris à dakar il ya les fameux raptor on
dirait bleus j'ai pas sûr apprécié dans
l'enclos way dans l'enclos ok ils sont
plantés ne sont pas encore ils n'ont pas
encore eu la bonne idée de les relâcher
à ce moment là comme le petit cochon
ils sont tombés
dans l'enclos ouais voilà pourquoi pas
quelle belle idée pourquoi pas après
tout il ya eu le terrain dont et où ils
font du canoë et on va pas me dire que
c'était pas prévu ils ont même pensé au
gilet de sauvetage
donc ils sont pas arrivés là par
accident ou par nécessité 1 c'est
quelque chose de prémédité là qu'ils
sont en train de faire du canonnier avec
le mozart voila voila c est là ils ont
limite repris exactement le même lycée
l'a signifié c'est la même scène que
dans le film c'est qu'ils étaient déjà
dans le trailer du premier film avec je
ne veux pas plein écran avec quand même
le souci du détail l'aidante les dents
terry gou vide je crois même est ce
qu'ils ont fait la langue fourchue
intéressant poursuit la langue
non elle n'a pas l'air d'être fourchue
lalande non ils n'ont pas poussé le
souci du détail au point de faire la
langue fourchue
normalement il aurait dû avoir la langue
fourchue vu que c'est un bar en personne
viendra te sauver
[Musique]
non
et
et oui c'est toi le meilleur on sait que
c'est toi le meilleur revient et puis il
ya quelques visuels en dessous donc on
peut regarder on peut regarder les
visuels
alors le premier c découvrez l'autre
côté de l'île
il ya donc ce serait de une partie de
l'île qu'on a jamais été ignorée et du
coup ils ont même deux minutes sauf s'il
ya ba ouais je sais pas il avait déjà ce
tunnel comme ça dans le premier vingt
deux minutes ils étaient moins jaune
rouge il me semble mais ouais il était
déjà en serpentin comme ça il me semble
bien là
d'accord d'accord moi je sais plus je
sais plus c'est pareil les temps d'un
don imus elle me ouais je n'y a aucun il
ya aucun théropodes qui a les dents qui
se croisent comme ça là qui n'ont on
appelle ça de la en anglais c'est un
terreau machine c entrelacés quoi y'a
aucun théropodes que ça c'est un truc de
crocodile quoi et encore même que des
crocodiles même pas des alligators ça
c'est dégueulasse au point où ils en
sont j'imagine que après tout il y avait
des grenouilles à la pâte maître du
croco et ya le fameux plus haut oui
voilà
ohlala alors je sais pas ce qui me
choque le plus c'est ce qui sépare à the
role of us luminescents luminescents ou
est ce que c'est le fait qu'ils sont
dans l'eau crois que c'est le fait
qu'ils sont dans l'oubli var départ à
the role of us dans l'eau ça nous ramène
aux heures les plus sombres du paléo
artis mme dû parler aux artistes isme où
c'est un truc qu'on n'a plus vu depuis
petits pieds collés par as the role of
us dans l'eau plus la taille la taille
elle est fausse mais ça doit être des
bébés j'en sais rien ouais c'est pas la
bonne taille quoi deux fils tim bref
mais les jeunes ils avaient réussi cette
crête comme ça non c'est un truc qui se
développement donc oui ça peut pas être
des routes
ouais c'est une tête d'adultes du ménage
pourquoi il se brouille les zombies dans
l'eau puis alors j'ai l'impression que
ces études c'est ça me fait penser à la
battère avait clairement un visuel
bâtard quoi donc voilà non mais dans
l'eau je veux dire je sais pas si tu te
rappelles là dans le premier jurassic
park
il est là il regarde les parazols of us
marché ils voient les brachiosaures
sortir de l'eau fx place un tampon c'est
la scène qui est censé te tirer les
larmes tu vois c'est là c'est la scène
qui est censée tomber brisé le coeur de
les voir marcher sur terre quoi ils
sortent de l'eau ils sont là et ils se
déplacent en troupeau ils sont pas des
crétins solitaire ce sont des des
animaux sociaux groupe est complet mais
je veux dire de toi tu les renvoie dans
l'eau quoi tu sais jersey
tu as vu le premier film quatre ans a
encore une insulte de plus au premier
film quoi te dire au delà même du
message paléontologique on s'en fout
mais là je veux dire le premier film
avait fait justement cet effort de les
sortir de l'eau et non contre les
renvois de dans les baux les bons gros
bestiaux du marécage bien crasse les
imbéciles doivent manger des algues et
l'épaisseur de leur corps comme d'un
tuba de retour dans les années 50 les
mains des mains en l'air mon salaire net
non plus les mains ça manque de sabu
s'est pas les sabots boule noire un peu
je sais pas là c'est pas c'est pas assez
pour juger mais ça manque
ça manque de possibilités de quadrupler
d'être quadrupèdes
évidemment ils vont pas être quadrupèdes
sinon ils ont mené qu'il plaît beaucoup
et pas un truc en canoë derrière des
bestioles là derrière on dirait un gros
bond je sais pas non non dans le cas
nous attendent
ah ouais vous avez servi qu'elle vient
d'une attention au zoom
si c'est pas un qui l'odeur des corps en
titre et ces noms là un christ et non un
an qu'ils n'y a pas le cas de colruyt
services telles que light avaient un
petit ankylose hors d'un système parce
que parce que la vie est trop courte
grave
ok ok bas depuis c'est comme tu disais
je veux dire on va lâcher les enfants
comme ça dans des canaux et au milieu
des dinosaures au baiia peut-être une
raison derrière mais enfin ce que je
veux dire c'est que s'il ya des cas mais
ça a l'air d'être un programme de la
visite je veux dire ça a vraiment l'air
de faire partie du truc
bah dis donc si les canaux et qu'ils
sont près pareil qui est sûr que tu
t'attends à voir des visiteurs ne veut
dire évidemment que tu lâches les les
touristes comme ça au milieu des
rhinocéros
oui et puis tu y vas leur gratouiller
actuellement tout est prêt pour la
bioluminescence parce qu'on va pas quand
même partir parce que l'afrique n'est
non plus bon sachant que de toute façon
c'est des trucs qui sont génétiquement
modifiés et on sait faire des méduses
bioluminescente depuis 1998 je crois ou
un truc comme ça depuis il ya des
poissons il ya des tas de trucs qui sont
violées ministre d'ailleurs on va dire
on va dire qu'ils leur ont
artificiellement à injecter des
bactéries bioluminescente tu vois la bo
du coup il ya de la méduse du poids sur
le dos d'il ya probablement de l'âme et
du poisson du lait de la bactérie on
sait pas ce qu'ils ont fait ceci dit bon
le côté le côté visuel est cool et
d'ailleurs d'ailleurs puisque puisqu'a
priori ils avaient utilisé ces genres de
cornes qui était sexuelle qui était dit
mort fiq quoi ça devait être un
caractère sexuel la bioluminescence si
elle avait été violée luminescentes ça
aurait été très efficaces ont été très
con pour échapper aux prédateurs mais ça
a été très efficace et passer des bons
si tu peux les faire bioluminescente est
dans une période que ces gens et quand
il joue bien
[Musique]
c'est là la patrouille
la patrouille des dinosaures d' y en a
un rouge et un bleu et puis se suivent
comme ça non c'est pour le troupeau il
suit dernier le dernier qui fait la
lanterne rouge c'est pour ça voilà il ya
rodolphe devant bien celui de derrière
qui attire l'attention des prédateurs
il fait ian malcolm qui il allume sa
torche les pili court comme un noeud
falloir utiliser beaucoup d y en a à
chaque fois qu'ils me voyais en a un qui
passe en salle et les voitures et les
vertes évidemment pas l'idée de famille
le fameux le girafe à titan avec ça son
coût tignes le stégosaure qui est encore
la queue qui traîne mais bon ça c'était
déjà dans jurassic world de convoyer le
patron ou le 1 je crois je ne suis plus
bas bref ils ont toujours la queue qui
traîne comme comme au bon vieux temps
les raptor qu'on a vu way peu mais c'est
bien plein oui bah tiens tiens ankylose
or c'est bien ankylose or qu'ils ont
abusé donc ils ont un toutou ankylose or
qui a l'air un peu new delhi qui disent
un peu merdé à l'autre oui c'est un an
qu'ils osent or il n'a pas une vision
binoculaire mais je veux dire juste
graphiquement il doit peut-être en même
temps c'est soit tu lui donnes ses yeux
la soie il louche
donc c'est vrai que c'est pas non il
n'ya pas de bonne solution c'est
maintenant qu'ils osent or ce n'était
pas la bonne idée un bébé j'avais
maîtrise et ça aurait été bien le bébé
tricia aurait fait clin d'oeil aux
livres mal ça peut être bien ça aurait
pu être bien mais non non non mais non
en kilos d'or c'est ouais je sais pas
ils ont tous des âges très différents
ils m'ont l'air des personnages en ont
les manières très jeune et puis alors
quelle manière
je prends plus âgés bon après c'est les
colonies de vacances des fois tu réunis
des impôts différents d'accord dans les
lignes tu prends des ados mais n'ont pas
forcément tous le même âge que lui plus
câlin qui l'odeur abba malla enfin le
caresser très très fort qui sentent
quelque chose
donc il ya un autre t-rex du coup ça
veut dire qu'il y avait un autre t-rex
dans le camp crétacé en même temps que
l'autre 1/2 que dans que dans le dans le
film ouais ou alors il rentre dans le
concret tassée après le ballon vu que du
coup ci c'est fort c'est pas si ça se
passe en même temps que les films
d'accord il ya une autre vidéo là je
sais pas combien de temps elle durera
j'avais pas vu ou là une heure cinquante
ans on va pas faire une heure 52 ton
seul analyste du trailer une analyse du
trailer donc c'est une analyse c'est
bien ça on peut faire une analyse de
l'analyse du trailer ça fait une
inception comme ça ouais non on fait une
exception d'analystes de trailer
lorsque le way attend peut-être on peut
revoir juste rapidement le tyrannosaure
pour ainsi celle même si on renvoie
tonton t-rex tout en tira les x6 et même
il doit avoir les espèces de traces de
griffes
[Musique]
défini il n'a pas les traces de
griffures donc c'est pas le même
dialecte
ils ont oublié ils ont juste oublié bon
niveau de hype
est-ce que s comprend netflix est ce que
ça vaut le coup de prendre netflix
d'accord ouais je pensais ouais non le
niveau de haye puis les îles et les
boucs le procès c'est vraiment le
problème de la saga je pense à de base
c'est que j'ai pas une grosse hype sur
la saga des jeux de base par près c'est
ce qu'on attend d'un trailer enfin c'est
pas fait pour des adultes non plus et
faites voter oui c'est vrai c'est fait
pour des ados et baal doux l'âge des
personnages vert donc pour nous c'est
sûr que ça va être un peu
ouais c'est pas censé nous parler non
c'est sûr c'est sûr c'est pas fait pour
nous c'est c'est certainement très bien
pour des ados ou des enfants je ne dis
pas mais ouais ouais ça puis alors ça ça
sent le la génération aléatoire d'un
cohérence avec les films mais c'est
tellement je pense que je vais plus
m'arracher les cheveux en fait pourquoi
le premier jour la six cordes j'avais
pas trop aimé parce que il ya tellement
de cohérence avec la manière dont on
gère un parc animalier nos jours c'est
juste pas possible en fait t'as des
normes de sécurité et à des tas des
choses que tu dois mettre en place tata
pas le choix et on his c'était c'était
clairement pas fait et du coup là je
pense que je vais aussi m'arracher les
cheveux parce que ça je sais pas avoir
des tas de situations qui ne devrait
jamais existé en fait ça peut pas
exister
normalement oui donc le des raptors
ouvert sur dessus clairement parce qu on
leur file à une volière
ou alors qu'il met les trucs pour faire
en sorte qu'ils puissent pas grimper en
fait
existe avec les clôtures électriques ou
dessus enfin t'as plein de choses à
mettre ça c'est pas possible
clermont c'est pareil le truc de l'inde
minus ou tel le tracker qui tu peux pas
le voir directement ou la fillette
décide d'ouvrir les portes avant de
regarder où il est le tracker c'est
juste pas possible tu as des protocoles
à mettre en place les choses qui doivent
arriver dans un certain ordre
normalement ça n'aurait jamais dû se
passer
donc oui c'est simple le fait qu'ils
aient pas de sas dans ce temps claude
n'y a pas un moment où c'est à dire tu
es dehors où tu es dedans y'a pas de
papa de deux petites de finasser
intermedia bas après sa note 'aaa'
taille importe il ya littéralement une
porte qui donne sur le dehors à
l'intérieur de l'enclos ça c'est quand
même pas normal ça normalement c'est pas
possible mais après il est possible
qu'ils aient une porte de ce style là
juste pour les premières livraisons pour
le premier truc ça ça arrive quand tu
construis ton enclos et une porte comme
ça mais après les jamais elle est plus
jamais ouvert quant à des animaux d'eau
mais par contre ça peut être utilisée
quand par exemple tu va ramener des
véhicules pour faire de grands
aménagements à l'intérieur et là
effectivement tu as une porte pour
véhicules qui va être ouverte ou quoi
mais normalement tu as une tâche pas
forcément là tu mais l'animal dans une
wheel c'est censé être compartimenté je
veux dire tu lâches pas des gens à
l'intérieur de l'enclos sans avoir mis
au préalable
l'animal oui et ça qu'on parie même
enclos là le fait qu'ils rentrent en dix
ans billy houle dit nous dire clairement
tu tchèque surtout si tu as un moyen de
traquer ton animal comme ça sur une
carte wifi qu'il est bien encore qu'il
est plus dans l'enclos avoir de
l'entraînement parce que dangereux
tu prends pas ta voiture pour aller au
gym qui rentre dans un enclos avec des
lions sans savoir si le lion il est pas
juste à côté pour tout simple pour
t'attaquer et au pire je sais qu'un a
beaucoup qui pensent que des lions c'est
des grosses peluches m'enfin c'est pas
le cas donc bon ben apparemment pas
l'air d'une grosse pilule de toute façon
non j'ai remarqué un truc un très très
bon point ces hétéros dont deux aux
russes là
[Rires]
parmi les jolies ya une bonne idée la
mettre un hétéro d'autoroute sur le côté
d'ailleurs ils ont même pas décoré
jusqu'en bas c'est dommage la bomba du
coup c'est on n'aura que ça pour
attendre jusqu'au prochain film donc ma
foi peut-être qu'on peut être qu'on dit
jettera un oeil
pourquoi pas faire une autre critique à
ce moment là au moins le premier épisode
lorsque ces artistes vont être
intéressants pour toujours peut toujours
suivre un peu comment ça
si si si les gens font des bonnes
critiques
pourquoi pas bon bah voilà c'était notre
petit notre petite critique à chaud du
trailer de gameplay thaçi russe la hype
et pas spécialement n'est pas
spécialement là mais au moins ça nous
fera attendre jusqu'au jusqu'à dans un
an quand le prochain
le prochain jurassique world sortira en
attendant vous souhaite de bonnes
vacances et amusez vous bien
mais y apporter vos masques c'était très
nue mais portez vos masques quand même
dit au revoir
[Rires]